my second movie was American Gangster
that movie was badel Wasington what's it
like acting next to somebody like Denzel
Washington so this scene right here
where he and I were together before we
shot this scene I was walking pacing
back and forth having a moment going
over my lines and he looked at me he
said man you nervous and I said well
kind of man just you know making sure I
don't this up he said man come here he
said look they could have had anybody
else right here doing this what you
doing right I said yeah he said but they
called you right I said yeah he said do
you know why they called you do you know
what you did to make them call you I
said yeah he said all right do
that then we ain't got no reason to
get